the rhetorical device we're going to
discuss today is the slippery slope
argument this is where someone claims
that one small first step can or will
lead to a chain of related events that
result in something consequential
happening usually something undesirable
something bad something we should try to
avoid this strategy can be used properly
but sometimes it's fallacious here's an
example of a slippery slope argument
you've been a regular smoker for some
time but you recently quit you haven't
had a cigarette for three months you go
to a concert and your friend who doesn't
know you've been trying to quit offers
you a cigarette you think to yourself if
I smoke this one cigarette
I'll just want another one later tonight
and then I'll want to buy a pack of
cigarettes tomorrow and then I'll just
become a regular smoker again so you say
to your friend no thanks I'm trying to
quit you've given a slippery slope
argument in response to your friend
you've basically claimed that once one
event occurs other related events will
follow eventually leading to unwanted
consequences the idea is that once you
take that first step down the slope
smoking the first cigarette in our
example then you'll quickly fall down to
the bottom of the slippery slope
becoming someone who smokes regularly
all over again here's what the argument
looks like if a then B if B then C not C
therefore not a in other words premise
if you smoke one cigarette you will
eventually become a regular smoker
premise becoming a regular smoker again
is undesirable premise you shouldn't do
what is undesirable our conclusion being
you shouldn't smoke that first cigarette
to figure out if this is a fallacious
use of a slippery slope argument we have
to evaluate it right the first test
would be looking at premise two are the
claimed effects actually undesirable in
this case yeah right the undisputed
medical consensus is that smoking
regularly is detrimental to your health
let's now test premise one the core of
the slippery slope if you smoke one
cigarette
you will event
truly become a regular smoker well the
science has actually shown that the vast
majority of ex smokers who smoke one
cigarette after quitting can't stop
there and return to their status as
regular smokers so there is at least
good reason to think that this premise
is likely true and third do the costs
outweigh all of the benefits of the
first event are there other relevant
factors that we should consider when it
comes to that first event which might
make the negative consequences worth it
in the end maybe you would enjoy that
one cigarette at the concert so much but
assuming that all of the other premises
are true it puts you at significant risk
for becoming a regular smoker again and
becoming a regular smoker is undesirable
for very good reasons therefore know the
benefits of smoking that first cigarette
probably are not worth the negative
consequences so this particular slippery
slope argument is probably sound but if
any of these premises weren't true there
would be a stopping point in the
slippery slope and then the slippery
slope argument would be fallacious and
unsound take this example premise one if
I join an airline's reward program I
will fly more premise two if I fly more
I will be in a plane crash I don't want
to be in a plane crash the conclusion
therefore is that I shouldn't join an
airline's reward program there are
multiple ways to break this slippery
slope multiple untrue premises premise
one joining an airline rewards program
doesn't necessarily mean that you'll fly
more it just means you'll benefit from
accumulating frequent flyer miles when
you do fly and premise to flying more
often doesn't mean you'll get into a
plane crash commercial flights are one
of the safest modes of transportation
and premise three certainly I don't want
to get into a plane crash but the other
premises don't hold up and we can
evaluate this slippery slope argument as
being unsound and fallacious assessing
the strength of slippery slope arguments
is not always this
black-and-white you've got to take into
consideration the probability that each
of the premises is true in evaluating
the overall soundness of the argument
especially because slippery slope
arguments aren't always intended to be
strictly valid which is to say if a and
B if B then C many people arguing a
slippery slope are merely intending to
say that this is a likely succession of
events so you have to ask yourself how
likely is it that B will follow from a
and C follow from B if it's very likely
then the arguer has a good case with
slippery slopes it boils down to
determining the plausibility and
likelihood of the premises if you're
interested in philosophy and critical
thinking you will love brilliant which
has pretty much become my go-to for
learning things online check out
brilliance new immersive lessons on
logic problem-solving multi level
thinking identifying false information
and identifying fallacies whether you
already have a grasp on any of these
subjects or you're looking for a fun and
engaging way to become acquainted with
these topics for the first time
brilliant really is the place to go
where you can actually learn hands-on by
solving problems and puzzles designed by
expert educators and unlike other
learning sites when I'm using brilliant
I'm actually learning by working
hands-on with real-world scenarios and
problems sign up for free by going to
brilliant org slash critical thinking
I've put a link in the description under
this video and the first 200 people who
visit will get 20% off an annual Premium
Membership visit brilliant org slash
critical thinking